l'incertitude continue dans un monde où
l'anticipation est le maître mot c'est
l'inconnu qui reste pour le monde
culturel au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'activité a
repris le 18 mai dernier avec la
réouverture de la billetterie consignes
à respecter et public plus clairsemé
on va être à 60 65 % de la jauge on a
aussi des abonnements qui permettent
cette souplesse puisque en plus des
abonnements traditionnels qui oblige
entre guillemets à prendre quatre ou
huit spectacles dès le départ là on a
également des cartes saison qui
permettent de prendre les spectacles 1
donc on essaie d'être le plus souple
possible du côté de coignières on a fait
le choix d'une saison progressive
la municipalité propose depuis la
rentrée des représentations courte d'une
heure avec des jauges de 150 personnes
on est sur un redémarrage de la saison
culturelle à coignières mais un
redémarrage en quelque sorte prudent et
au ralenti c'est pour tester si nous
avons un public qui se déplacent parce
que ça non plus ce n'est pas forcément
garantie même si on sent quand même qui
a une envie des gens quand même d'aller
de retrouver les salles de spectacles en
quelque sorte et de vivre tout
simplement
les grands spectacles professionnels
devraient reprendre la route du théâtre
alphonse daudet au mois de janvier 2021